monsieur bonsoir c'est une première
mondiale l'équipe du professeur
carpentier à paris a réussi une
intervention à coeur ouvert par
vidéochirurgie autrement dit à l'aide
d'une petite caméra introduite dans le
coeur après une toute petite incision
caroline glorion et franck brisset en
plein coeur précisément entre
l'oreillette et le ventricule gauche
le geste du chirurgien est d'une absolue
maîtrise une micro caméra vidéo dits de
l'intervention l'image est agrandie pour
faciliter le travail chirurgical une
future pour réparer un coeur endommagé
la patiente à 30 ans l'opération va
durer 2h30 c'est un peu comme un
spéléologue chirurgien spéléologues aux
descendants une cavité le thorax et
après on descend dans une autre qualité
qui est au coeur et puis là on trouve un
grand 10,4 x ou cinq fois des structures
qu'on connaît mais certaines que l'on ne
voit jamais parce qu'on ne peut pas les
voir parler vision habituelle
alors c'est très émouvant son aide de la
vidéochirurgie il aurait fallu ouvrir le
tronc du malade comme sur ce schéma à
gauche de l'écran pour cette
intervention l'incision pratique et ne
mesure que 4 cm un premier avantage le
choc opératoire et donc beaucoup moins
important il ya moins de perte de sens
donc moins de risques d'infection depuis
cette première opération par deux fois
l'équipe du professeur carpentier à
pratiquer des interventions à l'aide de
cet oeil électronique de fabrication
française